My life is reflected in my tattoos,
and you're going to have to trust me
when I say that I've got a lot of them.
My body art tells a story.
Now, my HIV tattoo
is on one of my kneecaps,
which is the joint that,
through a career of playing
professional rugby,
was shot to pieces,
but somehow managed to get me through
one of the world's toughest Ironmen.
And also, more recently,
a half-marathon.
Now, I did these to show
what living with HIV is like now,
and also to illustrate that HIV
doesn't restrict what I'm capable of doing
physically or mentally.
The skull is dark, ghoulish, threatening.
It represents the imminent death
that I felt awaited me
when I first had my diagnosis.
The wings underneath
the skull of my tattoo
signify the freedom I felt
when I finally found my voice.
It was almost like the dead man
coming back to life.
The crown that adorns the skull's head
shows me as someone willing
to lead from the front,
who wanted to take the campaign against
discrimination and misinformation forward,
who wanted to celebrate
and highlight people's truth,
never asking people
to do something I wouldn't.
Now, I haven't always been like this.
In 2019, I was blackmailed
by somebody who wanted money
for their silence.
Also, in that year, a journalist
went to my parents' house,
knocked on their door,
and asked my parents
to make comment on my HIV status.
Now at this point,
I hadn't even told my parents myself.
That forced me into telling the world
about my HIV diagnosis
way before I was ready.
I was still reeling from the stigma
of the diagnosis.
Now stigma is when people
are seen in a negative way
due to a certain characteristic,
such as race, disability,
sexuality or health challenges.
And it ends up with them making
a moral judgment about people,
and it affects the way they treat them.
Now, I have spent my entire adult life
in the public eye.
I'm an ex-professional Rugby Union player,
I played 100 times for my country, Wales,
captained the British and Irish Lions.
I always felt like I had the crowds
cheering me on from the grandstands.
Since then, I've presented
and appeared on many TV shows.
I've had an amazing life.
I felt loved by those around me
and by my country.
I was this strong, tough rugby player
who came from a simple
working-class background
to be one of the very best at this sport.
I was married to a woman,
but I was living a lie.
So in 2009,
when I became the first openly gay male
professional Rugby Union player,
it was a defining moment for me,
for sport and for society.
And even though it felt
like a breakthrough moment,
sadly, very few followed my path since.
I am now living with HIV.
It took me a long while
to process it at first,
because I'd gone from a man who had won
every trophy that he had ever dreamt of
to someone who,
all of a sudden, was living a lie,
who was ashamed, embarrassed, isolated,
afraid I was going to die,
afraid to tell anyone,
afraid to tell my family,
afraid I was going to lose
everything and everyone
that I'd worked so hard for
and I loved so much.
I was afraid that from now on,
I would be defined by a virus.
Now, I've felt the devastating impact
of stigma and shame,
and that is why I am determined to change
the way people perceive HIV
and other stigmatized conditions.
And here's why.
The stigma and shame that I felt
was medically unfounded.
Science and medicine has come
such a long way in the last 20 years,
especially around HIV,
that it should be celebrated
way more than it is.
But people's attitudes lag way behind.
The fact is, I take one tablet a day.
Modern medicine prevents my HIV
progressing into AIDS.
It suppresses the virus in my body,
which means it becomes undetectable,
which means I cannot
transmit it to my husband.
And I live a normal, happy, healthy life.
I really do. Trust me,
I have never been happier.
(Cheers and applause)
Now, in the 1980s,
HIV was positioned as a death sentence.
It was reported as "the gay plague."
And those myths and misunderstandings
still exist today.
And levels of awareness
of what it is to live with HIV
remain way too low.
Now I can tell you
I still experience stigma today,
whether it's people
moving away from me in a restaurant
or people not wanting to shake my hand.
Now people act like that
out of a sense of fear,
out of a sense of wanting
to keep themselves safe.
But what it does,
it creates a sense of shame.
And that shame means
more people acquire the virus
and fewer people get early treatment,
because most people think
that HIV doesn't affect them,
that it only affects gay and bisexual men,
when globally, 54 percent of the people
living with HIV are female.
And in England, in 2020,
for the first time in a decade,
there was more new cases of HIV
among heterosexual people
than there were
amongst gay and bisexual men.
The truth is anyone can get the virus,
and the only way to know your status
is to get tested,
but stigma acts as a barrier to testing,
so new cases continue.
In the US,
eight out of 10 new cases
come from people who are undiagnosed
or who are not on medication.
Now UNAIDS has set a goal
that by 2030, they will end this epidemic,
but it's going to be really hard to reach
if stigma continues to act as a barrier
against testing and seeking care.
Now, when I was pushed into a corner
by the blackmailer and by the media,
I was going to come out fighting.
I wanted to take control of my life.
I wanted to know
what it was like to feel free.
I wanted to know, and I had the right
to be able to live again.
And I wanted anyone else
who was in the same position as me
to have that right as well.
Now tackling stigma
is an ongoing challenge.
It's going to take a collective effort
from policymakers,
health care officials,
advocacy organizations
and, more importantly,
all of us in the general public.
Education is key.
The more people who know the facts,
the more the truth spreads.
Even simple conversations
between two people
can change minds.
Now we need to normalize talking about HIV
and other stigmatized conditions,
and I encourage you all to challenge
any stigma you encounter,
whether that be mental health,
race, disability, sexuality.
We also need to address
legal inequality and discrimination.
Now I feel relatively lucky,
given the strides being made
in this regard, living in the UK,
as I'm aware of people around the world,
who are living with HIV,
that, through discrimination,
have limitations placed
on what they can and cannot do,
or even on where they can and cannot live.
Now, recently, in the UK,
changes have finally been made
that means that people living with HIV
can join the armed forces and be deployed,
or can train as commercial airline pilots.
Now these changes have only happened
thanks to the determination
and advocacy of those involved --
people with a dogged determination
to create safe, stigma-free environments.
Stigma also exists in unexpected places,
like within health care.
You know, we’d all expect health care
professionals to know the facts,
but this isn't always the case,
especially outside of HIV specialists,
and this absolutely needs to change,
as this can have a devastating impact
on people living with the virus,
discouraging them from accessing care.
Now --
I am very, very, very proud
to lead the Tackle HIV campaign.
And we focus on that first point,
education.
And along with our charity partners,
the Terrence Higgins Trust
and ViiV Healthcare,
which is an organization fully focused
on eradicating HIV and AIDS,
we are using the power
of science, advocacy and sport
to change people's attitudes.
We draw on the ability of sport
to effect change,
the love of celebrity
and the compelling stories
of those living with HIV
can bring to change
people's behavior and understanding,
whether that be through media engagements,
a podcast with others
who have experienced stigma,
or live, on-the-ground initiatives.
I am passionate,
passionate about demonstrating
that HIV is not a barrier to anything,
whether that be through me
running an Ironman,
a half-marathon
or just through my daily gym workouts.
Vecause when people
can get beyond the fact
that HIV is no longer a death sentence,
and that on effective medication,
it can become undetectable in your body,
which means it's untransmissible
through sexual contact,
then people living with HIV
can live without fear
of rejection or alienation.
And so the fight continues,
because in some countries
around the world,
new cases of HIV are rising,
and in all of these countries,
stigma continues to exist.
I guarantee you,
one day, we'll reach our goal.
So when anyone encounters stigma,
regardless of what the source
of that stigma is,
we can all play a part in combating it.
We all have a part to play.
When you see or hear
any cases of stigmatization,
find the strength
to challenge and correct it,
whether that be at home with your family,
out with your friends
or even in the wider community.
Now, the wings underneath my tattoo ...
give me the strength to move beyond
HIV stigma and HIV shame.
And trust me, all of you,
please trust me --
if I can do it, then anyone can do it.
And then, and only then,
do we have a real chance
of ending HIV forever.
So please,
please, please help me,
because together, we can tackle stigma.
Thank you so much.
(Cheers and applause)